carl loewe lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren runde und
robin meine rollen gespielt ja dass wir
30 gespielt dass wir hat mittlerweile
schon einen namen bekommen einfach
scheiße in dem game gerade um gekaufte
tja das ungeschliffene hallo ich habe
ich nicht ungenannt
das war dauert macht genau bis zum start
los jetzt kenne ich gar nicht alles kann
aldi markt ist richtig
warum versuchen die kiste zu kriegen
weiß warum alter wo sind die kästen
versuche ich renne grad in richtung
tester und hoffe dass da noch eine kiste
okay ich hab ja zumindest dass es
dadurch auf der map schon sehr froh ich
weiß selber nicht genau wo die kiste
unbedingt alle sind und ja also aus
finden angeblich aus ab
ja das wäre auf jeden fall sehr kugel
ich habe nämlich gerade rein gar nichts
doch ich dachte jetzt mehr hier werden
ihr wissen ob es auch nicht
kannst mir irgendwas sichern oder so ich
bin ich zum ersten mal ich hätte gedacht
dass darin kommt ja ich habe auch gar
nicht gesehen was wir überhaupt dran ist
ja ich würde einfach mal sagen ich habe
ja nichts bekommen außerdem spielt das
heißt wir müssen das als zusammenbleiben
und hoffen dass wir beides partei sind
okay ich bin ich bin in russland ich bin
auch ins entlasten zu tessa treffen über
die bücherei ist du musst du beschreibst
du musst auf einen seite vom kanal
irgendwo lange muss auf der ein
richtiges sehe ich das monster da sind
viele leute dass bestimmte tester in der
lage sich welche dann will ich mal
lieber raushalten
ok ich hab' ich schon sagte tester ich
immer mit auf denen drauf ich versuchte
seine sachen zu kriegen
ich habe einen teil der geißbock so
richtig wo bist du denn engagierte
online alltäglichen holzschwert aber
mehr auch nicht okay aber das ist
langsam versuchen hier zu testen wo bist
du ja ich bin der mitte von dem web auf
dieser brücke wo bist du ja ich bin oft
der brücke da oben ich bin auf der
brücke da oben
nein ich bin bei seinem komischen keine
ahnung was ach du bist über bibliothek
gewesen
bei der bibliothek ja kein muss ist
unten und in die bibliothek unten rein
komme hoch hier sind übels viele sollte
die ich weiß nicht dass der skater ich
glaub ich mich gleich an
ich habe angst ich habe angst der stellt
angegriffen
aber der hat ja ich war später 68
aber die marke ich hab einfach mal
vertreter eingegeben
weil ich dachte so eine warnung bekommen
screen in minecraft achso minecraft ist
ein kleiner club werde ich dann noch mit
ihren sap gewesen
das jetzt auf 14 millionen bis 15
millionen 14 hatte jack crabb 23.6.2010
kinder hast bist du das ist sogar erste
pfiffe yorker ist auf eine gute sache
solche nämlich auch moment auf 181
traceure beide twittern oder vegas hatte
den spielspaß
ok ok gespielt jetzt kann ich sterben
hab ich mich auf ich nämlich durchaus
florenz zu machen du bist richtig gut
spielt hallo und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren runde doppel in mein will
heute mit dabei der liebe congo after a
konny reimann
ich versuche jetzt einfach mal pro runde
auf platz vier drin
vielleicht sind die ganz menschen wer
guckt mich die ganze zeit an ich weiß
noch gar nicht wo du bist was travel im
18 jähriger hast du ne na.de crafter 21
okay ich bin um gespielt es ist nicht so
der pvp übers klo xd
ex-boxer motto jetzt geht's los
das weiß ich ging in der heimat ein
schwert hastreiter hingeben o fortuna
die players auf fakten und hast du angst
hast euch geschafft ich habe es auch
nicht geschafft das wahre viele weiß was
jetzt machen die runde machen
euro pro runde hält jedoch fast gar
nicht doch es geht darum den plan
du musst auf das auf die insel oben
drauf kommt mit mist als anzeichen einen
mega plant auf die insel auf der insel
direkt neben dem mann hast du dir als er
heute ich bin direkt in dir drin weil
ich die ganze kiste eingesammelt stehe
ich vor dominierend noch eine kiste
zucker tannenholz vorn zu kommen
kommt er geht an zu dieser kiste wo ich
blind bin dies fast immer leer also das
was da ist fast nie da gewesen sein ich
werde auch der zweite insel will ich
darauf dass gerade und vertrete oder ich
bin auf der trader ich bin auch auf der
trader insel nicht jeder im haus witten
und wer mich getötet mit diesem trailer
für euch sofort töten ich bin weiter
bestätigt nun auch in russland die
taktiktafel cookie und ich hab so angst
ich hab so angst die sind zwar auf der
bühne der woche sich daher box ist da
ich gehe zum test jetzt gerade
so richtige pro runde simon hatte mich
schlägt auch ein typ ich bin oft tot
ich bin wirklich total isoliert er mich
einfach dass im greater trm klären
ich war und mich ein detective sauber
schreibt eine leitung spielt twitter
bisschen zu spät mein lieber freund
bisschen zu spät ab ist zu spät also den
spaß muss sein gefährt oder wird gleich
ein spannender kampf hier und er ist
fast tot er wird abgeschossen von
igoogle und da bekämpfen sich welche
rationell p versucht zu klettern wachsen
thm war übrigens kein trader der warnow
hauptsache mich haben einfach die ganze
bremseingriffen mich hat auch ein demo
getötet das ist richtig geld
obwohl ich schon minecraft dj craft a21
celtic park noch eine runde dran weil
die bisher relativ kurz waren
für laster zu lesen ohne hilfe juh 66
habe ich noch hätte simon kräfte 21 ich
hätte es nicht
nick ist ein richtiger name weil keine
ahnung testfeld voll auf das was ich
selber ist heute gilt weil dieses video
werde ich gemacht habe dass mir das
damals gar nichts gebracht
nicht zusammen
so ist nun einmal eine neue programme zu
starten was wollten wir
wir wollten klopf klopf wird eine treppe
bot 11 bitte ok hallo und herzlich
kommen zu einer weiteren runde joggen
will heute mit dabei kaum crafter nein
ich halte zu entkräften 21
krasser dabei ich bin dabei weil ich bin
ein profi deswegen hat mich ungespielt
gefragt ob ich ihm ein paar tipps geben
könnte und ja auf jeden fall genau
gedacht ich übernehme hier einfach den
kanal bringen hat tipps bei und ja die
met ist klopp wird island blockade müsse
erst mal merken ist englisch natürlich
ne clockwork das blog world ist
natürlich uhren lance ist es im inland
und umwelt ja genau
reiche world is the world ist natürlich
land der welt als englisch erst mal dass
die hauptsache die man wissen muss und
damit gewinnt man eigentlich alles und
dann seitlich gibt es extra an und
direkt an die runde startet machen ist
spekulativ eine kiste sofort ja mach ich
hier mache ist eine richtige wir rocken
jetzt alles okay okay
es lag man sogar kontraktes kanal kennt
ist weiter ist es jetzt noch nicht so
der bvb ii der ist jeder anfänger die zu
der anfang sagt weiter ich bin oft
wetter ja erfüllten als 30 aus weil ich
habe auch schon nicht aber schon bei
journalisten sachen ich habe alles
erreicht wohl zutreffen
wir treffen uns jetzt oben in dem haus
des sports sind oben beim eisenstädter
ja ich versuche mir noch kurzen bogen zu
holen ok ich halte seine kraft 21 heimen
kraft der gutes zeichen
ich habe einstein stadt und bogen wir
gehen wir gehen dahin wo wir wir gehen
dahin wo wir richtig trader knopf
drücken
was er ich bin doch ich weiß wo ich
meine ich bin 30 sekunden habe ich doch
noch mal spricht ja okay da unten bist
du dass simon nicht kaputtgehen gespielt
trader jetzt machen wir nehmen die kiste
hält nicht bekommen bin immer hoch teile
ich hoffe ich kriege die kiste gar nicht
weil hier so viele leute da rumstehen ok
braucht drücken wie bekloppt schottland
mecklenbeck kommen ihr die tür aus
kommentiert ein anderer ich bin bei dem
stück ich bin bei dem schiff um zum
schiff und zum schiff 33 herz ich habe
drei herzlich mit mir jetzt ein bisschen
zurück debatte sollte ein kind einmal
gilt
du musst mit mir hier oben bleiben warte
ich komme direkt ich komme direkt zurück
ich muss so gerne erstmal mein herze
aufgaben machen
ich habe angst einer kommt ich bin auf
dem weg weiter auf der hauptwache konto
ja ich komme ich komm ich komme
der trailer ist mit dem ansatz zusammen
im skiff und den nichts getan er hat ihr
bestimmt also diese bestimmt freuen oder
so der ist hoch kommt glaube ich hab ich
den jetzt bin und da hat nichts getan
wie menschen verletzt
ich komme wieder auf dem weg nach oben
bist du denn noch im leben da ich rede
von laurie der habe ich unterstützen für
den erzfeind woche danke gott ich hab
noch ein herz gott gott im himmel
lasst mich jetzt bitte nicht sterben hab
grad in detective wickelt das trading
tätig betont alter nein warum man ich
hatte zwei trailer peter bin ich
gestorben
er hat mich bitte gekillt warum
nein ich habe schläge bekommen was ist
das für ein scheiß ich wieso bin ich
gestorben
ich hatte zwei überfälle gekauft das zum
im test aller geschossen die therapie
kann die karten jetzt einfach ein
bisschen gespielt das wetter nämlich
versuchen herauszureißen
ja das ist ja dass ich leute noch mal
ganz kurz tipp auf dieser map entweder
hier oben bleiben und warten bis welche
die leitern hoch kommt das gleiche ist
auch bei dieser anderen
dort könnt ihr euch auch bei diesem
schiff da einfach oben hinstellen oder
was auf dieser map ja auch noch gutes
ist da und ist ein kleines gebäude da
sind so spinnen leben vor
ihr könnt euch einfach hinter die tür
stellen wenn ein bisschen kempten trader
seid könnt euch einfach dahinter die tür
stellen hier so hin wo ich gerade stehe
hier warten bis einer konzertierten am
green nahm dann einfach drauf packen
wenn ihr drin sind das eigentlich die
beste taktik hier auf der messe ist aber
ein bisschen feige
also ich hab mich die ganze zeit sondern
höchstens bisher zwei punkte hatte mit
ihr euch überholen könnte dann müsste er
loslegen
das ist auch sinnlos
ich würde sagen es war er mir viel als
pro jahr
ja man kann ich immer glück und es ist
halt auch oft viel glück das glück ist
mit die doofen wie viele kameras noch
23.000 87 sap 2410 von freude wie man
mit einer dürftigen einer ein like
dalassen ziehen was auf deutsch
einsammeln damit wir das hier nicht
anders so somit an die zitzen
vollstopfen weissbrodt fast alles war es
weg pumpen ist ganz auf zweck man sagen
und das machen 2 ab
ciao